hey guys so i thought we'd try something
a little bit different this week loads
of stuff happened and i thought maybe
instead of trying to compartmentalize
everything into the work social and
oxford specific stuff i could go through
my week chronologically and just sort of
explain things as they happened so let's
travel back in time to the distant past
of monday i came back into the lab after
the weekend and found that the code that
i'd written to do my job for me over the
weekend had one error in it so i had to
fix the code in the morning which didn't
take very long because it was one line
which was wrong
and set that running then in the
afternoon i had a meeting so i'm part of
the ocean and climate group um whilst
doing my master's project and we meet
every other week to discuss what we've
been doing in the past fortnight so um
for instance i was presenting the work
which i'm doing my linear stochastic
modeling and saying well we've got
everything set up now we're just waiting
for the computer code to run whilst for
example one of the phd students in the
group was presenting his work on um
modeling ocean convective currency you
have these really deep ocean currents
going through say the pacific
of water a different density because the
different salt content for example and
trying to represent that in a simple
model on tuesday i went to the library
in the morning to finish off some notes
on a textbook that i needed in order to
do my problem sheet for the week then i
went to the lab to look at the results
which i my computer finally produced and
then in the afternoon i had the
privilege of being able to go to this
climate symposium so
loads of different departments in
knoxville do climate research it's not
just atmospheric physics you've also got
as you'd expect geography
earth sciences and they also had some
representatives from the economics
department and it all took place in the
sheldonian theater where when you come
into the university you take part in a
ceremony called matriculation where you
officially become part of the university
and then it's also where you graduate
and you collect your degree it's a
really interesting research that's going
on and they were talking about
everything from looking at the effects
of volcanoes on the atmosphere looking
at the economics of
things like carbon trading carbon taxes
we also had one of my lecturers don
granger who was talking about measuring
the atmosphere from space using
satellites and sort of some of the
physics that was involved and then in
the evening i was spent almost all
evening reading up on uh papers for
reasons to become clear on wednesday but
i left the library for just a couple of
hours to go to the physics society
social and elections so i'm a member of
the committee for the physics society
i'm head of publicity but there are
loads of different positions you know
the secretary treasurer president or
that kind of stuff and we are elected by
members of the physics society and in
order to be elected we have to have
elections we had drinks and snacks and
pizza
and it was a great chance just to meet
physicists from other colleges and sort
of all have a bit of a moment about the
work so wednesday was the reason i was
reading one of these papers it was
because i was going to this phd open day
at the university of reading i was
shortlisted to attend this this day
there are about
27 28 people there i think unfortunately
for me um the supervisor which i was
really interested in um wasn't there so
unfortunately i've gone all the way out
to reading for nothing which was a shame
but a chance to wear a seat then i came
back from reading went to the lab got a
few more results from my programs set a
few more programs running
and then
went to see brian may as in rock god
brian may of queen so the oxford union
uh hosts speakers like brian may all the
time in fact most days of the week but
this time around it was brian may and he
was speaking on the badger cull um so he
talked for about half an hour about this
issue which he's really passionate about
and then we had a big q a session and
that ranged from everything from the
magical to his uh doctor in astrophysics
to a large section on his music career
so compared to all the different things
which happened in the previous couple of
days thursday was a kind of boring day
but it was a very
essential day because i had a problem
shooting on friday and so i was working
pretty much
all day
and when i say all day i mean from about
10 in the morning till about 4 00
in the morning so then friday i kind of
i guess already covered a little bit um
i went to the library early i just got a
couple of hours of sleep went back to
the library carried on working until i
just couldn't do any more went to the
department handed in what i had and then
went to the lab to do a little bit more
programming and finally get some
concrete results down so it's almost
like the first phase of my project is
now definitely complete and now there's
an extension to the word which i'd like
to do so jamie you asked me in your
video what the most inspirational
speaker that i've been to in oxford have
been i think if i had to choose
one person which was really
inspirational it might actually have to
be brian wax the physics society talk
from last week about string theory
purely because he really got me buzzing
again about theoretical physics you just
get to see so many people here it's very
difficult to choose one person which
really defines you so last week i asked
my subscribers why they want to do the
subject they're going to do or at least
what they're going to say to their
tutors in their interview
why did you choose to do ppe and my
question to you guys the viewers this
week i've been talking about a lot of
the awesome extracurricular stuff that
you get to do in oxford like symposia
and the union that kind of stuff so what
do you see yourself getting involved
with once you get into oxford that you
do outside of your subject as ever if
you have any suggestions for what you'd
like me to cover or questions like to
ask leave them in the comments and i
will see you next week for the last
video of this term